after college I moved to Shanghai which
is where I met my wife ice we got a
couple small lizards as pets when we
were over there she really liked those
so we came back to the US one of the
first things we did was divers grown up
with her like she's totally in love with
him my guy was like my son
he's pretty affectionate like he really
enjoys human company interaction he eats
one large meaty meal about every one
week right now
right but we give them lots of random
fruit treats throughout the week like
clicks thanks MacGyver's favorite food
is probably it just looks really cute
that really excited when he eats the
amamiya kids then crab
I think lizards generally are
misunderstood most people I don't think
had enough interaction with any lizards
that really get a sense of how
intelligent they can be McGuyver has a
message for the world giant lizards can
be friendly and adorable
give him a couple minute look over
before you make up your mind
good job this is a crown
you